[Musica]
500 anni prima di cristo un ricco
signore andò da uno scultore voleva
farsi fare una statua lo scultore si
mise subito al lavoro e dopo un po ricco
signore andò vedere a che punto era la
lavorazione arrivò nel laboratorio e la
scultura nella sua parte davanti era
bellissima e perfetta
il retro no e ha abbozzato era
incompiuto bruttino ma il ricco signore
piaceva talmente tanto che ha detto la
porto a casa subito no no disse lo
scultore non è finita sì ma io ho io la
voglio portare a casa tanto la metto
contro la parete non la vedo la parte
brutta perché l'ho scritto uno scultore
lo guardò e disse lei non la vede ma gli
dei si
e potrebbero arrabbiarsi
questa storia l'ho trovata in un libro
di peter drucker che è considerato il
padre spirituale e il padre fondatore
del management e ci dice una cosa
fondamentale
quando progettiamo qualcosa costruiamo
qualcosa non è importante solo la
bellezza e prendersi cura della bellezza
che si vede ma anche della bellezza non
visibile
io l'ho fatto per anni l'ho applicato
negli eventi che citava elisa cioè mi
preoccupavo non solo che il percorso
dello spettatore fosse pulito che l'area
hospitality fosse arredata bene che lo
stadio d'arrivo fosse bello armonico
uniforme mi interessava anche il dietro
i processi organizzativi metodo la
strategia le relazioni con le persone il
rispetto con tutte le persone con le
quali lavoravo
e di questo oggi vi parlo perché negli
eventi questa bellezza non visibile si
complica un po o meglio
si allunga
tempo fa un personaggio molto famoso
della televisione disse questa frase
l'unica cosa che conti davvero negli
eventi sportivi
è quanto ti ubriachi
l'ha detto lui
homer simpson è un cartone animato ok è
una finzione però pensiamoci bene quante
volte organizziamo gli eventi con una
grande ubriacatura metaforica ci
interessa solo il momento la sbronza
collettiva il divertimento le grandi
emozioni l'energia fuochi d'artificio
l'esperienza usa e getta e tutto il
resto poi non ha importanza
questa cosa l'ho vissuto anch'io nel
costruire la bellezza visibile quella
non visibile perché lavoravamo un anno
intensamente così per ogni evento lavoro
i lavori crei energia costruisci si
allestisce tutto gli eventi finiscono di
colpo e mi ritrovavo lì così è finito
l'evento io avevo tutta questa energia
non deve finire tutto ciò e così ho
deciso di cercare il senso degli eventi
per prima cosa forse per deformazione
formativo ho studiato letteratura
all'università o perton dizionario
etimologico
avevo l'evento deriva dal latino che
significa e venire cioè venir fuori
accadere ma soprattutto dentro questo
senso c'è l'idea del movimento
l'evento è
come il vento è qualcosa che passa
impalpabile c'è e poi non c'è più poi
sono andato a chiedere aiuto anche ad
alcuni filosofi e non chiusi a una
filosofa però ho cercato e ho trovato in
un filosofo francese paul ricard una
risposta per me bomba davvero importante
perché se un evento è un accadere
e ciò che accade passa paul ricard dice
ciò che passa non si lascia pensare se
non il rapporto ciò che permane la
sostanza cioè cosa vuol dire vuol dire
che l'evento ha senso non solo nella
ubriacatura del momento ma soprattutto
senso del suo dopo in ciò che lascia è
che il filosofo chiamo la sostanza
la bellezza del gesto atletico che
diventa una fotografia il palazzetto che
ospita la competizione che diventa la
palestra per i bambini sostanza
l'emozione che proviamo noi nel vedere
questa cosa e questo mozione diventa
memoria e dunque un pezzetto della
nostra identità
sostanza
l'atleta che fa questa gara e vince la
medaglia
sostanza
la città che guardava all'entroterra e
ha iniziato a guardare e vivere il mare
barcellona 1992 forse l'olimpiade più
citata per la sua potenza di
rigenerazione di trasformazione non solo
nella percezione ma proprio nella vita
delle persone di questa città
ma c'è un'altra città che è stata
un'altra sede olimpica che è stata molto
citata
atene 2004 le piscine abbandonate e una
sedia
sostanza anche questa è sostanza
allora molti di voi diranno
evidentemente qui non c'era un piano di
sostenibilità che può darsi no siamo
sicuri che il problema sia la
sostenibilità perché magari questa
piscina durante i giochi era sostenibile
il problema e ve lo ricordate
l'esperienza usa e getta quello che
accade dopo e così sono andata ad aprire
di nuovo il dizionario etimologico
la prova la sostenibilità deriva dal
latino che significa sostenere tenere
sopra ora sia chiaro la sostenibilità è
fondamentale ed è importante che se ne
parli ma dipende da che punto di vista e
in che modo se guardiamo la parola la
parola è tenere sopra quindi io sono
dentro questo evento rosso tengo sopra
cosa nuotate
rispetto
all'evento
l'evento è
dinamico la sostenibilità è statica c'è
comunque un fritto concettuale tra
queste due cose io posso essere
sostenibile dentro l'evento ma l'evento
ha un senso nel suo passare non nel suo
essere
e la sostenibilità parla di star tenere
fermi
e quindi ho pensato che cosa possiamo
utilizzare quali altre parole potenti
abbiamo e ho trovato questo la cura
potenziante l'evento si prende cura di
tutto ciò che tocca di tutte le persone
che tocca che attraversa dei luoghi
delle comunità in modo potenziante la
parola cura è una parola realmente this
raptis provate a immaginare nella vostra
quotidianità di e io mi prendo cura di
di un lavoro di qualsiasi cosa la cura
che fare con l'empatia con l'ascolto col
rispetto al rispetto vuol dire vedere
davvero capire ed ascoltare davvero
ma potenziante perché anche la cura può
essere statica noi la vogliamo far
crescere la vogliamo sviluppare vogliamo
che dio movimento alla sostanza che
resta dopo
la cura potenziante crea la capacità di
evolvere io non solo mi occupo di ciò
che resta dopo ma faccio in modo che ciò
che resta dopo possa continuare a vivere
trasformarsi rigenerarsi il palazzetto
dei campioni che diventa palestra dei
bambini questa è una rigenerazione do
nuova vita
oa di rete si va beh ovvio le olimpiadi
le piscine le cose grande ma gli eventi
non sono questa cosa sto usa lontana
solo dei grandi eventi
la nostra vita è fatta di cambiamenti
evoluzioni trasformazioni continue gli
eventi sono solo come come dire un
momento di accelerazione di
concentrazione del cambiamento di
propulsione e sta a noi decidere
che direzione mandarla questa
trasformazione
questa può essere una rappresentazione
degli eventi può essere un olimpiade una
coppa del mondo un festival culturale
una sagra di paese
una convention una fiera
una riunione è un micro micro mico
evento una riunione
proviamo a mettere la parola cura
potenziante dentro una riunione che cosa
cambia nel nostro approccio in ciò che
vogliamo portare fuori dopo quella
riunione e ognuno di questi nodi a
seconda della dimensione può essere un
territorio una comunità un palazzo o può
essere anche solo tante persone delle
quali noi ci prendiamo cura
l'evento questo evento sta per finire
provate a pensare dentro di voi che
trasformazioni ci sono o ci saranno
avrete una memoria un'immagine una
parola che vi ha trasformati vi
trasformerà ci sarà qualcosa e ai
ragazzi e le ragazze che hanno costruito
tutto questo insieme alle aziende che
cosa resterà di che cosa si sono presi
cura in modo potenziante e questa
comunità che ci ha accolto
questo evento diventa l'ubriacatura di
homer simpson è un evento che avvia un
nuovo cammino
l'evento sta per finire anche il mio
tempo vedo
l'evento sta per finire
ma la fine di un evento non è mai la
fine è sempre solo l'inizio di nuove
storie e sta a noi decidere che
direzione e che nutrimento dare a quelle
storie
l'evento è un passaggio in cui ci si
prende cura di un germoglio
come questo seme è piccolissimo ma fate
finta che sia un evento non so se lo
vedete
questo se ne un evento io posso
ingoiarlo alla homer simpson e poi
sputarlo posso farlo cadere per terra
abbandonarlo qualcuno ci camminerà sopra
e questa è la fine scorie non resta
nulla oppure ne aveva un altro questo
seme
io lo posso mettere qua e trasformare
questo seme in un alberello che magari
diventa un bosco
io questo lo chiamo l'evento gentile che
si prende cura del seme nel suo essere
evento per il germoglio del domani
[Applauso]